hey Luke here with the outdoor men
YouTube channel and for those of you who
follow my channel you may have noticed
that there's been some changes recently
last week YouTube discovered that bad
people were sometimes leaving
inappropriate comments on YouTube videos
thanks to the hard-hitting journalists
at BuzzFeed this new problem was
discovered by our great and benevolent
leader chairman Susan Wojcicki may her
reign be a thousand years so in order to
protect our children from the seedy
underbelly of the Internet YouTube has
decided to disable all comments on any
channel that features children YouTube's
decision has also affected the channel
formerly known as the outdoor voice so
in order to protect my children and in
order to keep this channel
family-friendly I have made the decision
that from now on I will only be making
adult videos unfortunately as much as I
love making videos with my son's Tommy
and Nathan will no longer be featured in
any of our videos from now on we are
going to be using only adults I'd like
to introduce you to our new adult
co-hosts Sir Mario Franklin and mr.
Godzilla are you a child sir Franklin no
well you have a very nice beard so
obviously you're not a child
this is sir Franklin he's 48 years old
and a native of Kalamazoo Michigan he
enjoys making videos grooming his beard
and going to chick-fil-a I don't like
mr. Godzilla is almost 100 years old he
is originally from Paris France when
he's not leveling buildings he enjoys
playing with his toys watching paw
patrol and vamp arena hello
that's an excellent mustache you have
sir Franklin mr. Godzilla thank you for
joining us here today I think you folks
at home are really gonna enjoy this
video and remember you can still
communicate with us and join our
community on Facebook or on Instagram
I'll put links in the video description
enjoy the show
[Music]
alright guys welcome to another episode
of the outdoor men youtube channel and
today we are doing an extremely gruesome
and graphic video be warned if you're a
fruitarian or very squeamish at the
sight of pulp you may not want to watch
this video we're gonna find hunt gut
cook and eat our own veg let me
introduce you to the crew and show you
what we're gonna be using to catch our
vegetable today few short to me oh yeah
that's a great looking slingshot mister
guards illa what are you what are you
using oh you got the SOG tactical
tomahawk my brother here is carrying the
Benjamin trail point two two caliber
pneumatic rifle now I am going to be
using ninja throwing stars because
they're awesome we might find a few
vegetables getting out of their den and
forging a little bit and if we can do
that we're gonna be eating vegetable and
I love those stay upwind eggplants have
excellent senses of smell
[Music]
oh look at that that's it's just a great
shot now now when they're still
twitching like this you got to put them
out of their misery and you use a use a
priest ah
[Music]
any feeling pain no more little buddy no
more pain yeah look at this eggplant
that is a fat one deboned this thing
probably weighs close to a pound keep
them in the bag
there we go see right there see what's
on that stump it's a pumpkin how to
sneak up close to it okay oh okay he's
dead man he's dead he's dead it's over
yeah do a broccoli call doing a little
Ted Nugent
[Music]
there you go there you go dad
congratulations look at that
you dropped a sick beat we were dead
tomato honey okay all you need it's a
couple sticks oh that's a beautiful one
this is sashimi grade Tomatoes right
here okay probably the best way to eat a
fresh kill tomato sashimi style maybe
with a little salt on it mmm well this
has been a pretty successful a little
hunt we're just kind of poker heads
around a little bit and see if we can't
get some potatoes or carrots yeah he
didn't even twitch oh that is savage
look at that oh yeah that he didn't
suffer well this has just been an
amazing hunting trip so far but I got a
little spot over here where there's a
lot of Chinese radishes people used to
keep them as pets around here and then
let them go and they've just become so
invasive so we're gonna see if we can't
pluck a couple Chinese radishes here Oh
check out right up there in the tree
there's two of them right in there if
you shoot the top one he'll fall down on
this buddy and scare him so you've got
to shoot the bottom one first and then
you can get both of them
all that one up there still alive let's
see what yeah there we go nice daikon
yes other ones he's dead
oh look at that bullet went clean
through
Oh waste not want not fresh white radish
all right we got a nesting spaghetti
squash here we're gonna see if we can
take it out with the tomahawk look at
that great clean kill right through the
vitals oh hey look
it was tagged I'll have to call that in
my wife's gonna be thrilled she loves
spaghetti squash I think we're gonna do
some good eatin here so listen guys
we're gonna take this back to the house
and I'm gonna show you how to gut it
clean it and eat it well my grandfather
with me and we're gonna show you how to
cook these vegetables now a lot of you
when you think of vegetable hunters you
think of those trophy hunters that go
out to Africa to go shoot a
thousand-pound yamp just so they can put
some leaves and stems up on their wall
and that's that's not what we're about
here we're really about being able to
know where your food came from and so
we're gonna show you how to butcher and
prepare those vegetables
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's the beats une domes - ants on a
log fried pumpkin seeds blackened
eggplant fresh broccoli with dipping
sauce and we've got some tomatoes and
salt and fried beets and dill and basil
not too shabby
and you don't care about any of it he
just wants his bananas well this is a
good meal that tastes even better
when you've killed it yourself so we're
gonna tuck into this and looks pretty
good yeah well hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video it had a good laugh
I'm not sure what YouTube is gonna do
about the comments maybe they'll
reactivate comments before I get done
editing this video who knows yeah nobody
really knows what's going on but stick
with us guys and if you want check us
out on Facebook and Instagram so you can
be a little bit more part of the
community I'd love to hear your feedback
tell me what parts of the video you
liked it didn't like so that I can we
can make better videos in the future but
thanks for watching and don't forget to
click Subscribe and put out new videos
every Saturday morning thanks guys if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching this
is way too much fun